hi I'm John Landau producer of Avatar in
the way of water
I'm here today with our cast and we are
back together 13 years later pretty
exciting yeah it is right
the first film was a discovery of the
forest a discovery of Pandora on your
Banshee outstanding it was unlike
anything any of us had ever seen
and now it's the way of water and it's a
world all on its own and I felt like I
was rediscovering Pandora all over again
one of the things I love about this film
is that you're introduced to the kids
and the story of course is about how the
family will change alien that's all they
see I see
and that's what Jim's very good at he's
he's very good at up in the antique he's
very good at well we're going to add
children into this love story we're
going to increase the planet and what we
see of it
if you think you're going in and seeing
a rehash of the first movie it's not
it's an extension
[Music]
what is Ava's heartbeat sound like
mighty
wherever we go
this family
is our Fortress
[Music]